RAYMOND ARROYO IS HERE WITH A
SPECIAL MONDAY EDITION OF SEEN
AND UNSEEN.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 28, AMERICA IN
SHUTDOWN.
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS HAVE LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS,
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE WHO WE ARE
TOLD ARE THE STANDOUTS, THE MOST
LEARNED PROFESSIONALS IN THEIR
FIELD.
I’M TALKING ABOUT POLITICS AND
THE MEDIA AND IN SCIENCE.
LET’S REMEMBER WHAT WE WERE
HEARING OUT OF NEW YORK.
THIS IS JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
POLITICIANS WHO MADE A
ENORMOUSLY EXPENSIVE REQUESTS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BASED ON DATA THAT TURNED OUT TO
BE FALSE.
>> ALL THE PROJECTIONS SAY YOU
COULD HAVE AN APEX NEEDING
140,000 BEDS AND ABOUT 40,000
VENTILATORS.
WE ARE FOLLOWING THE DATA AND
THE SCIENCE, AND THAT’S WHAT THE
DATA AND THE SCIENCE SAYS.
>> Laura: THOSE CLAIMS WERE
BASED ON THE FAULTY MODELS OF
THE IMPERIAL COLLEGE OF LONDON
STUDY.
AND THERE WERE PROFOUND
IMPLICATIONS, TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SPENT, BASED ON THE FEAR
THAT THOSE NUMBERS WERE AT LEAST
IN THE BALLPARK.
WE WERE TOLD THAT THE AMERICAN
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WAS IN DANGER OF
COLLAPSING IF WE DIDN’T FLATTEN
THAT CURVE.
WELL, THE NUMBERS WEREN’T EVEN
CLOSE.
>> ON BEHALF OF DOWNSTATE
NEW YORK, WE ARE IN A POSITION
NOW WHERE WE ARE NOT GOING TO
NEED A VENTILATORS, WE ARE GOING
TO BE OKAY, EQUIPMENTWISE.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY
DRAMATICALLY.
>> NO ONE WHO HAS NEEDED A
VENTILATOR HAS NOT GOTTEN A
VENTILATOR.
NO ONE WHO HAS NEEDED A HOSPITAL
BED HAS BEEN DENIED A HOSPITAL
BED.
>> OUR HOSPITALS WERE NOT
OVERWHELMED AND ARE NOT
OVERWHELMED AT THIS HOUR.
>> Laura: THAT IS GREAT NEWS.
IT’S 100% CORRECT.
THETHE I HME MODEL FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON HAS THE
LATEST NUMBERS AND PROJECTIONS.
RIGHT NOW THERE IS ZERO SHORTAGE
OF ICU BEDS ZERO SHORTAGE OF
VENTS.
THE PROJECTED NEED FOR
VENTILATORS ON THE PEAK DAY IS
14,407 NATIONALLY.
THAT’S NATIONALLY FOR ICU BEDS,
WELL, GUESS WHAT?
THE NUMBERS JUST KILLED THE
ESTIMATES ORIGINALLY.
AND BY THE WAY, ANOTHER COST OF
THESE LAME PANIC-INDUCING
MODELS, IT LOOKS LIKE WE REALLY
DIDN’T NEED THE USNS MERCY OR
THE USS COMFORT IN NEW YORK OR
LOS ANGELES.
AMERICANS SHOULD BE FURIOUS
ABOUT THIS.
OF COURSE THE MEN AND THE WOMEN
IN THE SHIPS ARE DOING THEIR
PATRIOTIC DUTY.
THEY’RE AMAZING.
THE COMMANDERS, AMAZING.
BUT THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY THAT
WE ARE SPENDING ON A RESPONSE
THAT WAS BASED, AGAIN, ON FAULTY
NUMBERS.
LONG BEFORE THE GOVERNMENT
FIGURED OUT THAT THESE FANS SAID
COVID-19 MODELS WERE WRONG, MY
OWN LITTLE TEAM, LITTLE BAND OF
STATISTICIANS THAT ARE A LOT
SMARTER THAN I AM INSISTED THAT
THEY HAD ALSO CRUNCHED THE
NUMBERS.
THIS WAS WEEKS AGO.
IF THEY WERE MAKING DECISIONS,
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE, BASED ON
WHAT MY TEAM SAID WERE WILDLY
INCORRECT ASSUMPTIONS AND
ULTIMATELY INCOMPLETE DATA.
SO IT WAS 18 DAYS AGO ON MARCH
MARCH 24TH I PRESSED DR. FAUCI
ON NEW YORK’S SPECIFIC
VENTILATOR IN ICU BED REQUEST.
>> IF THE NUMBERS ARE NOT RIGHT,
THEN MAYBE THAT AFFECTS THE
DECISION-MAKING ABOUT WHEN THE
COUNTRY CAN GRADUALLY GET BACK
TO BUSINESS.
>> YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
LAURA, THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
FEMA IS WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
STATE OF NEW YORK TO TRY AND
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT THEY’LL
NEED AT WHAT TIME.
IF THE TOTALITY OF 30,000, WHAT
DO THEY NEED NOW, NEXT WEEK, THE
WEEK AFTER?
WHAT YOU’RE RIGHT, THOSE KIND OF
MODELS DO HELP INFORM US.
>> Laura: WELL, IT WAS KIND OF
AN ANSWER BUT NONANSWER.
MY QUESTION IS IF MY GUYS KNEW
THE NUMBERS WERE WRONG, AND THEY
DID, WHY DIDN’T THE EXPERTS KNOW
THAT THE NUMBERS WERE WRONG AS
WELL?
WHY DIDN’T WE ADJUST OUR
SHUTDOWN STRATEGY GIVEN THE HUGE
READJUSTMENT IN, FOR INSTANCE,
THE KEY NUMBER, THE MORTALITY
NUMBER?
THE PRESIDENT TODAY INDICATED
THAT HE DID SUSPECT THAT CUOMO’S
REQUESTS WERE WAY TOO HIGH, BUT
HE KICKED INTO ACTION ANYWAY.
>> FORTUNATELY WE DON’T NEED --
JUST LIKE WE DIDN’T NEED AS MANY
VENTILATORS WHEN THEY WERE
ASKING YOU NEW YORK FOR 40,000
VENTILATORS, I HAD EXPERTS --
THESE PEOPLE, I LISTEN TO THEM.
THEY SAID YOU’LL NEVER NEED THAT
MANY.
AND THEY WERE RIGHT.
>> Laura: WELL, HE WAS RIGHT.
HIS INSTINCT ABOUT THAT WAS
RIGHT.
AND NOW THE BLAME GAME OF COURSE
HAS BEGUN BECAUSE OVER THE
WEEKEND, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ATTEMPTED TO MAKE THE CASE THAT
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI AND OTHERS,
THEY WERE URGING THE PRESIDENT
TO SHUTDOWN THE COUNTRY I GUESS
EARLIER.
FAUCI SAID THIS TO JAKE TAPPER.
>> YOU COULD LOGICALLY SAY THAT
IF YOU HAD A PROCESS THAT WAS
ONGOING AND YOU STARTED
MITIGATION EARLIER YOU COULD
HAVE SAVED LIVES.
OBVIOUSLY NO ONE IS GOING TO
DENY THAT.
IF WE HAD, RIGHT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN,
IT MAY HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT BUT THERE WAS A LOT OF
PUSHBACK ABOUT SHUTTING THINGS
DOWN BACK THEN.
>> Laura: WAIT WAIT -- KIND OF
CLARIFY THIS AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE BUT WHAT WAS HE
CAUGHT TALKING ABOUT THEIR?
AT THE END OF FEBRUARY HE
HIMSELF WAS SAYING PUBLICLY AND
PRESUMABLY ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT THAT THERE WASN’T ALL
THAT MUCH TO WORRY ABOUT.
WATCH.
>> SHOULD WE BE CHANGING OUR
HABITS AND IF SO, HOW?
>> RIGHT HERE AT THIS MOMENT
THERE’S NO NEED TO CHANGE
ANYTHING THAT YOU’RE DOING ON A
DAY-BY-DAY BASIS.
YOU’VE GOT TO WATCH OUT BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH THE RISK IS LOW NOW,
YOU DON’T NEED TO CHANGE
ANYTHING YOU’RE DOING.
WHEN YOU START TO SEE COMMUNITY
SPREAD, THIS COULD CHANGE.
>> Laura: BASED ON THESE
PROJECTIONS, THAT AGAIN, WE’VE
GONE THROUGH WEEK AFTER WEEK
WERE WRONG, FAUCI AND OTHERS
EVENTUALLY DID PUSH FOR A
NATIONAL SHUTDOWN AND IT PLACES
LIKE NEW YORK, CAN MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT THAT WAS NECESSARY
THERE, BUT NOW -- YOU LOOK AT
ALL OF THESE OTHER STATES
BECAUSE TAX REVENUES AREN’T
COMING IN -- AGAIN, BEYOND
NEW YORK.
NEW YORK IS A CASE IN AND OF
ITSELF HERE, NUMBERS ARE SO BAD
THERE, BUT THE STATES WANT MORE
FEDERAL BAILOUT MONEY.
GOVERNORS LARRY HOGAN OF
MARYLAND, ANDREW CUOMO OF
NEW YORK AT A BUNCH OF OTHERS
ARE TEAMING UP TO DEMAND
$500 BILLION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT’S RIGHT, HALF A TRILLION
DOLLARS, 11 ZEROS.
THE QUESTION IS, WHERE’S THAT
MONEY MONEY GOING TO COME FROM?
I GUESS WE WILL PRINT IT, WE
WILL BORROW IT AND WE WILL END
UP WEAKENING OUR COUNTRY IN THE
LONG RUN.
LOOK FOR HUGE TAX INCREASES DOWN
THE ROAD TO PAY FOR ALL OF THIS,
WHICH OF COURSE WILL FURTHER
HAMPER ECONOMIC GROWTH.
NOT THAT THE MEDIA GIVES A DARN.
THEY’RE TOO BUSY TRYING TO BLAME
TRUMP FOR NOT LOCKING DOWN THE
COUNTRY FAST ENOUGH EVEN THOUGH
HIS MEDICAL ADVISORS HAD NOT YET
SUGGESTED THAT.
HE SPENT PART OF HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY SETTING THAT
RECORD STRAIGHT.
>> BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING FAKE
NEWS AND I LIKE TO HAVE IT
CORRECTED.
THEY ARE SAYING WHAT A GREAT JOB
WE’RE DOING IN THE MEDIA --
THESE ARE THE GOVERNORS OF
CALIFORNIA, GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY, GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
NEW YORK.
IN NEW YORK, VENTILATORS WERE
GOING TO BE A PROBLEM -- THEY
DIDN’T HAVE A PROBLEM.
BEDS ARE GOING TO BE A PROBLEM.
I’M HAPPY ABOUT IT, THE CENTER,
WHICH IS INCREDIBLE IS ALMOST
EMPTY.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS, NOT BAD NEWS.
THEY TOOK SOME CLIPS AND THEY
JUST RAN THEM FOR YOU AND THE
REASON IT IS TO KEEP YOU HONEST.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO
WORK.
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAVE ANY
IMPACT.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT IS
REALLY FRUSTRATED, OBVIOUSLY.
THE MEDIA SPAN ON ALL OF THIS
HAS BEEN OUTRAGEOUS.
ALL THE WHILE, THEY IGNORE THE
COST, OF COURSE -- THE OTHER
COSTS THAT ARE PILING UP HERE.
MEDICAL PROCEDURES THAT PEOPLE
ARE PUTTING OFF BECAUSE THEY
WERE AFRAID DUE TO THIS CRISIS.
THE COST TO OUR CITIZENS’ MENTAL
HEALTH BECAUSE OF FORCED
ISOLATION, THE COST TO FAMILY
HARMONY, CHILDREN’S WELL-BEING,
BEING KEPT OUT OF SCHOOL.
AND OF COURSE THE COST TO OUR
CIVIL LIBERTIES.
DURING EASTER WEEK AND LIBERAL
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS MOVED
AGAINST PEOPLE OF FAITH
DISTURBING WAYS.
IN SOME PLACES EVEN OUTDOOR
RELIGIOUS GATHERINGS MORE PEOPLE
REMAINED IN THEIR CARS WERE IN
LEGAL LIMBO AND THEY HANDS ON
THE WHIMS OF STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS.
MAYOR GREG FISHER OF LOUISVILLE
HAD HIS POLICE HARASSED
CHURCHGOERS AND THEIR TWO -- WHO
ACTUALLY DARED TO ATTEND
SERVICES, AGAIN, IN OUR CARS SO
IF YOU SIT IN YOUR CAR AT A
LIQUOR STORE, YOU’RE FINE.
BUT NOT AT A CHURCH.
A FEDERAL JUDGE SLAPPED HIM WITH
THE TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER.
IT WAS BLISTERING, WE ARE GOING
TO GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
BUT I SAY IT’S TIME FOR CONGRESS
AND FOR STATE LEGISLATURES TO
GET BACK INTO SESSION.
IF THEY TRULY BELIEVE THESE
ONGOING SHUTDOWNS BEYOND
NEW YORK, BEYOND THE HOT SPOTS
ARE NECESSARY, THEN IT’S TIME
FOR THEM TO PASS LAWS MANDATING
THEM.
STOP HIDING BEHIND EMERGENCY
DECLARATIONS FOR A VIRUS THAT,
WHILE DEVASTATING, WILL PROBABLY
IN THE END, ACCORDING TO THE NEW
PROJECTIONS, TAKE FEWER LIVES OF
WORKING AMERICANS THAN HEART
DISEASE OR THE FLU.
GET BACK TO WORK SO THE REST OF
US CAN DO THE SAME, CONGRESS.
THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE END